as I was saying so obviously as someone
that grew up in a single parent home
you've got an understanding of like
where you know you may have lacked
without having the dad so how do you
feel about that the only thing I can
come up with as if I go down on the
memory lane is when I was really young
obviously my father was struggling with
alcohol so he was an alcoholic including
most of my other family members and
basically what I can relate to is when I
started to have a realization of I'm
missing someone and when I met with him
I'm not quite sure how old I was maybe
six or so I just remembered that moment
when I said goodbye to him I was just
going to a park having a walk with him
and my mom probably was talking with him
about some serious family issues and
basically I just saw him saying bye to
me and I was crying so hard and I
couldn't explain the feeling that I was
missing out that
I realized that I'm more like a father's
daughter girl like I'm more like into I
want to have a father but it's really
difficult to explain because I never
actually had so I had stepfathers
obviously who I looked up to as a father
figure but I never actually been able to
call anyone father okay okay so how do
you how do you feel like not having a
stable father in the home may have
affected your development in into
becoming a woman
to be honest no because for me someone
is a father by their actions not because
they made me so I would I actually
considered my stepfather who was in my
life for almost eight years more like a
father to me than the actual father by
Blood okay so for me that means more
that he was teaching me guiding me
giving me basically everything that I
needed during that like seven eight
years or so before my mom and him broken
up so basically
I considered him more like a father
because of the things he has done for me
so I cannot really say that I missed my
father just because because you had
someone there yes exactly because it's a
thing where you you was lucky you know
what I mean because I feel like well in
my experience most people that did grow
up like in a single parent home they
probably didn't have a a steady guy
there to fulfill that role to get what
I'm saying so yeah I understand I
understand where you're coming from okay
all right I'll move on to the next what
do you think what do you think about it
so I'm in the same position where
growing up uh I was 13 when my dad died
and it happened really unexpectedly when
he was on holiday in Spain with my mom
and just randomly um had a brain stroke
and passed away so going back to the
topic it's one of those things where you
don't know what you don't know like I
don't know how I would have turned out
or how my behavior now would be
different if I did have a father figure
but what I can say is you know at such a
young age a lot of our beliefs beliefs
and attitudes around men as a woman is
modeled off what our parents teach us so
the only thing that I saw was that my
parents had a good relationship but
growing up you know through my teenage
years I never had my a father to tell me
you know how to date how to have a
healthy attitude towards men so I had to
learn a lot of that myself
okay all right do you feel the same way
or like you know you had your dad there
he was helping you kind of navigate I
wouldn't sorry for going back for that
but I wouldn't really say he was mainly
a dad to me I think he was kind of
tolerating me because he was together
with my mom so he had to take on some
sort of responsibilities because I was
there by force kind of thing but yeah
it's like if you date like a single mom
and they have a kid from a previous
marriage or relationship you sort of
love the woman and you have to accept
their child because you love the woman
so you have to be a father figure at
some point okay can I ask you a question
since you come from this you like this
situation if you had a son
would you would you feel comfortable
with your son getting into that kind of
situation where he coupled up with a
woman with children or would you kind of
advise him to know you know probably get
with a woman that doesn't have children
what would you advise your son I don't
think there is anything wrong with
dating anyone who already has a child so
I don't really think that something that
you can plan ahead like let's say I want
to meet with a guy fall in love with him
get married have a family have a child
and let's say in a 10 years or so
something goes wrong
what can I do about it I'm gonna be a
single mom with my own kid or two
it still doesn't mean that I don't
deserve to be happy and find someone who
has to accept that I have a kid so I'll
get that but like obviously do you think
it would be an advantage or a disavoage
if like just you know for your son would
you advise that because like in my
opinion like and this is an unpopular
opinion I feel like
for a man who is probably childless and
you know he has his ducks in a row he
has his everything going right for him
he probably would be best suited to get
with a woman who is childless because
just like you said
your stepdad took on a role and you know
you said wow your own mouth he tolerated
you yeah you know what I'm saying it's
definitely like their disadvantage and
obviously the connection he has with you
is going to be different to a connection
he would have his own biological
children do you get what I'm saying so
again that's what I'm asking you in
Ideal World you know in the future if he
had a son would you would you would like
you know be okay with that you would you
advise it would you deter him from doing
that maybe I probably would advise to go
for someone who doesn't have a child yet
so probably would be a bit more easier
okay but again we cannot really control
these things I guess well the man can
control these things
okay you can go on dating app you can go
on the dating app and be like oh women
with children or women without children
yeah I definitely have this filter on
you know you've got a daughter so you
got to feel right it's okay like come on
man
all right um did you have anything more
you wanted to add to it I was gonna say
I personally would if I were a man I
would not date a woman who's got
children a single mom
um because firstly like as a man if you
are going to be the one providing why
you're at a disadvantage providing for
someone who isn't your biological son or
daughter right and the second thing is
not not trying to victim blame but I
think
as a woman if you're having children
outside of wedlock or outside of
committed relationship it also says
something about you meaning that to an
extent you could be more responsible KO
what do you think about it
ah my my dad played a very important
role obviously I come from a family
where both mom and dad was together in
it and I'd say it definitely had I'm
from Southland so you know so of course
especially London but it played a role
in having a dad to kind of like as much
as you're not really listening because
you're growing up
and as much as we say our parents have a
it's our environment that kind of really
guides us and wants to tell us where we
want to go we hear a lot of what our
parents say in it but my parents weren't
born do you understand so there's a lot
of things for me I never felt like they
understood because they're coming with
their own teachings and all upbringings
because they're not from here absolutely
and after as I go as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible